hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about IBS tips
irritable bowel syndrome if you have
that listen and learn because there are
several things that you can do to really
greatly reduce the pain inflammation
bloating in your intestines number one
gluten now you probably already know
this gluten is the protein in grains
okay specifically wheat and you probably
already gave that up but if you haven't
if you just cut out gluten you probably
will notice 50% of the symptoms go
completely away overnight okay and but I
don't want you to have any grains
because it's hard to digest grains and
there's not a lot of nutrition and
grains either so just to avoid them all
you probably already did that but I just
want to mention that's the top top thing
and by the way if you're allergic to
gluten the reason why you're allergic
because the true allergy is to a protein
and gluten is the protein in the grain
okay the same thing with dairy see
sometimes people think chickens and eggs
are dairy they're not dairy is milk
derivatives anything from milk cheese
milk yogurt kefir
that's dairy and so you have the protein
in dairy it's called casein and you
might have a casein allergy okay but you
also could have a lactose intolerance
that's different but that can create
digestive problems so with IBS you have
a combination of allergies and
tolerances and just sensitivities okay
two different foods now this is really
cool number three when someone comes in
with an IBS flare-up I always ask them
number one when did it happen
okay when number one number two what did
you eat but normally they can't remember
so they don't keep a food lock so what I
want you to do is keep a food log
because if you can isolate when you
started having problems and then you
knew what you ate then we can narrow
down very quickly what you need what's
irritating your gut okay is it an
allergy is it a sensitivity and the
problem is when you eat a lot of
combination of foods you know it's
really hard because there's too many
variables so if you have IBS it's better
to have maybe one or two foods that
time that you're eating so we can narrow
it down and just from a process of
elimination we can find out what you can
eat and what you can't eat okay
don't keep eating things that are
irritating your gut alright so when did
it start what did you eat keep a log
very important fermented foods that
would be like sauerkraut kefir things
that are already broken down those are
easy to digest very smart to start
eating these foods if you have IBS
because it helps heal the area there's
other products you can take too like
glutamine and even cabbage juice is good
but that will actually help like
fermented cabbage juice is even better
but that will actually help the IBS now
the last thing we're talking about is
acid stomach now if you're consuming an
allergy the purpose of the stomach is to
break down proteins including things
that you're alerted to which are
proteins okay so if your stomach is too
alkaline
you're not going to break those down so
it's going to bypass the stomach these
proteins get into your small intestine
and irritate that heck out of your colon
creating all sorts of problems
so just by acidifying your stomach you
can create a lot of benefits so I use
something called apple cider vinegar
plus this has a concentrated outside of
vinegar plus something called betaine
hydrochloride which basically acidifies
your stomach and what happens is that if
your stomach is acid you will be able to
break down things that you're allergic
to at the stomach level and not them let
them invade the rest of the intestinal
tract where they're irritating the heck
out of your intestines there's a huge
connection between your pH especially of
the stomach and allergies okay
people develop allergies in general and
talk about food allergies and
environmental when they have an alkaline
system an / alkaline system okay you
maybe have heard the opposite but it's
not true it's an alkaline system so if
you were just to acidify the system you
would probably get rid of more allergies
okay so it starts with the stomach
stomach is the most important one
acidify so getting in our stomach help
break things down less irritation in the
gut alright hope that helped I will see
you in the next video